ask yourself the question what is your
ideal vision for the numbers you see in
your bank account what is your ideal
vision for your family and your
lifestyle and get as clear as possible
and chances are you're not as clear as
you think you are whatever comes to mind
pour out onto the page and then start
investing in yourself but the clarity is
you're not investing in a random way
you're investing in a specific way
because whatever you wrote on the page
is now going to clarify how you should
surround yourself with resources podcast
videos books people that are actually
the key vehicle of carrying you towards
your vision